YOUR FRIEND OR THUMP THEM ONE.
I'M TIRED OF BEING PUSHED
AROUND.
>> JIM, THE INCIDENT THAT SHE
STARTED TALKING ABOUT, WHICH IS
THREE EMPLOYEES RESIGNED OVER
IT, AND THERE WERE REPERCUSSIONS
FOR ERRORS THAT THEY MADE.
HAS ANYONE IN THIS WHITE HOUSE
GIVEN ALL THE LIES OR UNTRUE
STATEMENTS -- HAS ANYONE'S
HEAD -- HAS ANYONE HAD TO RESIGN
BASED ON, MISTAKES THEY HAVE
MADE SO FAR?
>> SO FAR, ANDERSON, NO.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT FOUNDED
BIRTERRISM AND PERPETUATED THE
MYTH PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS BORN IN
ANOTHER COUNTRY.
WHEN HE SAID HIS INAUGURATION
CROWD SIDE WAS BIGGER THAN
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S, NO ONE HAD TO
RESIGN.
WHEN HE SAID HE WAS WIRE TAPPED
AT TRUMP TOWER, NO ONE HAD TO
RE
RESIGN.
WHEN HE SAID HE HAD TAPES OF JIM
COMEY, NO ONE HAD TO COMPLAININ
THEIR JOBS BEING DIFFICULT OR
COMPLAINING ABOUT NOT BEING
RESPECTED?
>> I THINK APRIL MAKES A GREAT
POINT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT US.
IT'S ABOUT WHAT THIS PRESIDENT
IS DOING.
LOOK, I SEPARATE FROM THE
PRESIDENT FROM HIS WHITE HOUSE
PRESS STAFF BECAUSE SOMETIMES
THEY'VE SHOWN PROMISE FOR DOING
SOME THINGS.
I CREDIT THEM FOR BRINGING IN
PEOPLE FROM THE CABINET TO TALK
TO US IN SOME OF THE BRIEFINGS.
I GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR ALL THAT.
BUT THIS PRESIDENT HAS
UNDERMINED US FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
HE'S CALLED US ENEMIES OF THE
PEOPLE.
HE HAS TOLD US WE ARE FAKE
MEDIA, AND HE IS TRYING TO
UNDERMINE AND DRIVE A WEDGE
BETWEEN THE ELECTORATE AND US
AND WE ARE THE PUBLIC.
WE ARE THE REPUBLIC.
SO IT'S ATTEMPT TO GO UNDERMINE
THE FIRST AMENDMENT, HE'S TRYING
TO UNDERMINE THE REPUBLIC TO
SELL A MESSAGE.
AND THE MESSAGE IS WHAT I SAY IS
FACTUAL AND WHATEVER ELSE YOU
HEAR IS NOT.
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE THAT
LISTEN TO THAT BUT SLOWLY I HAVE
TO TELL YOU I WAS -- I KNOW OUR
FRUSTRATION IN THE ROOM, AND JIM
HAS KIND OF LED THAT STRUGGLE.
THE THING HE WENT THROUGH ON
MONDAY IN THE PRESS ROOM KIND OF
LED INDIRECTLY TO WHAT HAPPENED
TO ME AND APRIL WAS THE FIRST
ONES TO SPEAK UP IN THAT PRESS
ROOM.
THE THREE OF US TOGETHER, I
DON'T KNOW, BE IT COULD BE
DANGEROUS.
THE POINT BEING IS THAT IN THAT
ROOM WE HAVE FELT THE TENSION.
BUT AFTER WHAT I SAID YESTERDAY
I'VE GOTTEN PRESENTS FROM PEOPLE
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN -- I STRUCK
A MERV.
I DIDN'T EX INSPECT TO STRIKE A
NERVE OUTSIDE THE PRESS ROOM.
BUT I THINK THE PUBLIC IS